يعود او لا يعود الى البيت الابيض في كل
الحالات سيكون اسم دونالد ترامب الاكثر
جدلا في تاريخ رؤساء الولايات المتحده
وعندما يتعلق الامر بقضيه فيدراليه ولائحه
اتهام في 49 صفحه تضم 37 تهمه فالامور
ستكون معقده من كل النواحي وبسيناريوهات
لم يشهدها البلد منذ قبل من بين التهم
الموجهه للرئيس السابق حيازه وثائق السريه
عرقله العداله وانتهاك قانون التجسس اصدار
بيانات كاذبه في حال الادانه قد تصل
العقوبه الى السجن ما لا يقل عن عشرين
عاما والغريب ان كل هذه المعركه القانونيه
لن تلغي امكانيه الترشح ترامب للرئاسيه
المقبله
القوانين في الولايات المتحده تنطبق على
الجميع مهمه فريق الادعاء لن تكون سهله
والقضاء الامريكي ربما اكبر اختبار يتعرض
له يامل المدعي الخاص المكلف بالقضيه ان
تكون المحاكمه سريعه كيف وهل من الممكن
تطبيق القانون على الرئيس سابق يمكن ان
تراس محاكمته قضيه عينها هو في 2019 يعتبر
تشارت نفسه بريئا وان قضيه صناديق الملفات
السريه التي كانت بحوزته والقضايا الاخرى
المرتبطه باحداث الكونجرس ومحاوله قلب
نتائج انتخابات 2020 كلها في اطار مساعي
خصومه السياسيين للاطاحه بطموحاته للفوز
بفتره رئاسيه اخرى سيمثل امام محكمه ميامي
الثلاثاء المقبل اي عشيه عيد ميلاده
السابع والسبعين ليفقد الامل في مواصله
حشد الاصوات داخل الحزب الجمهوري لترشيحه
لانتخابات العام المقبل منافسه في البيت
الجمهوري وخلال التجمعاتهم يكتفون
بانتقاده ووصفه
مرشح غير اللائق للمنصب يحاولون استماله
قاعدته الانتخابيه التي لا يستهان بها
القضايا الفدراليه وغير الفيدراليه التي
قد تقوده الى السجن حتى الان لا تقلصوا من
حظوظه للفوز بالترشح ما يجري مشهد غير
مالوف في البلاد يخلط الاوراق ويكشف عن
ثغرات في الدستور واخرى قد تظهر خلال
الايام المقبله ويضع القضاء امام امتحان
صعب جدا 17 شهرا تفصل الامريكيين عن
الانتخابات هل ستكون المده كافيه
للمدعنه لسجن ترامب ام سيستغلها لاسقاط
التهم عنه وجعل المعركه القضائيه دعايه
انتخابيه من نوع اخر في بلد كل شيء فيه
يتعلق بالرئيس السابق ليشبه ما قبله من
زمن ابرهم لينكولن وحتى هذه اللحظه
الولايات المتحده ودونالد ترامب مسلسل
امريكي سياسي صاخب من الواقع المفتوح على
كل شيء غير متوقع وغير مسبوق